I understand the president is now on the
line President of the United States 45th
president Donald J Trump mr. president
thank you for being with us sir
hello Sean I want to tell you Gorsuch I
want to tell you Cavanaugh you have
released the whirlwind you will pay the
price you won't know what hit you if you
go forward with these awful decisions
you heard from the Chief Justice today
that sounds like a threat to me
your reaction well first of all let me
start by saying dr. Siegel I thought it
was terrific tonight and I really
appreciate the words I have a lot of
respect for him he's a real professional
and as far as humor is concerned it was
a terrible thing he said I was I was
amazed by it and if that were a
Republican you would see really bad
things happening it's very very unequal
justice and it's a disgrace that he was
able to say something like that and he
wasn't shielded by the halls of Congress
like Schiff was when he lied about my
phone call where he made up a phone call
and gave it in Congress and you
immediately say good we'll take it to
court but he's got immunity because he's
talking in Congress and so he totally
made up a there was a fake phone call he
just totally made it up his speech and
it was disgraceful well his humor did it
outside on the streets in front of a
rough crowd so it was it was a disgrace
to the Supreme Court and to the US
Senate mr. president my analysis of last
night in the lead up it seemed the media
has ignored this Bernie Sanders was
again doubling down on supporting one
murderous dictatorship regime after
another it seems like there's not a
whole lot of policy differences between
the candidates maybe Mike Bloomberg was
an exception on issues but supporting
murdering dictatorships I would argue as
a tipping point your reaction to that
and do you think that impacted last
night in your reaction overall to last
night well I don't know what impacted
last night I think Elizabeth Warren who
was did terribly last night but she got
enough votes that if Bernie Sanders
would have had those votes that I assume
he would have gotten vast
he would have won to all of those places
or certainly most of me would have won
Texas he would have wouldn't Minnesota
he would have won Massachusetts so
Elizabeth Warren really what she did and
you know others left they dropped out
and they supported Joe Biden and that
really helped now Joe didn't work that
out but somebody within that group
worked it out that was smart but Joe
would never be able to do that and but I
will say this Bernie Sanders had he was
if he were able to convince Elizabeth
Warren to endorse him or even to just
drop out because she's doing terribly he
would have won a large number of the
states that he lost last night there are
a lot of issues that I see I I know that
people are acting perhaps as though it
doesn't exist I there Joe Biden is
beyond a gaffe machine I would argue
that the toughest job in the world is
your job to be the president of the
United States of America leading the
world you need strength you need stamina
you need focus you need the ability to
react in real time what do you make of
these numerous gaffes of Joe Biden well
look I don't want to be too critical I
just you know I've never seen anything
like it to be honest and I'm sure that
the Democrats are saying the same thing
but they'd rather have them then birdie
and Bernie doesn't make too many gaps
but Bernie's got his own difficulties
but the way they push and you know look
the media is all over their side when I
say all all but a little bit including
yourselves and some of the folks on Fox
some of the folks around you have some
great people you have Rush who's doing I
hear really well he's doing much better
and Mark Levin and you know I mean we
have a lot of support you'd be amazed we
have a lot of support the great Lou
Dobbs so many people we have as
supporters outside of just you know our
our Fox News which you know I have my
own little I have my own little
difficulties with if you want to know
the truth they put people on that I
think
inappropriate and say very very false
things and people don't challenge him I
think they tried to be very politically
correct or fair and balanced right is
the term fair and balanced but I think
they hurt themselves if you want to know
the truth
mr. president I have not seen this
reported much the turn out for you is
spin record-breaking and that goes
starting back with Iowa New Hampshire
last night you received more votes in
Vermont Minnesota in Massachusetts than
any incumbent in the last four decades
in Colorado Republican turnout for you
last night this is an uncontested
primary greater than the past three
Republican primaries combined in Texas
you received more votes last night than
Bernie Sanders Joe Biden and Elizabeth
Warren combined and we're seeing similar
results in every state how do you
interpret that well I appreciate you
saying that I've heard those numbers I
have not read them in any media I don't
read those numbers because they don't
tell us those numbers but the people get
it John the people are genius the people
are brilliant in so many ways they get
it but you don't read those numbers
those numbers aren't broadcast for the
most part I've never seen him I've heard
of my guy had heard that and I heard
that we broke records all over the place
and never once ever seen it and I'm
pretty good with the media I see a lot
of the media what's going on I haven't
read it I haven't seen it well I like to
pride ourselves on this program giving
news and information that they ignore
let me ask you because we now know that
there is a corruption issue and there's
an investigation officially in the in
the country of Ukraine as it relates to
Joe Biden who said you got six hours
you're not getting the billion unless
you fire the prosecutor investigating my
zero experience on hunter being paid
millions after all you went through and
now that you see Ron Johnson in the
Senate and you see Ukraine investigating
this issue and then the other countries
such as China the Peter Schweitzer
writes about in great detail that hunter
again no experience making tons of money
do it has to be a campaign issue how do
you plan to use it or do you plan to use
it well to show you how crazy it is it's
not a campaign issue
for the Democrats they don't want to
bring it up they were obviously told you
can't bring that up so even people that
are against if you look at Joe they're
against Joe they don't want to bring
that up that was off bounds I watch
certain reporters say that this is
totally unsubstantiated it was started
to even ask you a question
Anderson Cooper said he asks a question
at what are the debates that was so mild
and a ridiculous answer is given because
there is no answer to it of course it's
corrupt and so he gives a really bad
answer and they go into the next
question nobody says anything the other
the other people that are running trying
to beat him don't bring it up that
wouldn't happen with the Republicans I
can tell you I'm not saying good better
and different but that certainly
wouldn't happen with the Republicans and
you know it's incredible that will be a
major issue in the campaign I will bring
that up all the time because I don't see
any way out I don't see any way out for
them I don't see how they could answer
those questions and maybe they can I
hope they can
I've actually preferred that they can
but I don't believe they'll be able to
answer those questions that was purely
corrupt any thoughts in your mind why
you think Barack Obama has not endorsed
his vice president of eight years well I
would say because he didn't think he
could make it he didn't think he had a
shot at it
you know he's dealing with people that I
didn't rate the highest on the political
scale I know everybody and I look at
even a party I know I know people that
are Democrats that are far above that
with what you're watching I watched one
night and I looked at the cast of
characters I said this is a 350 million
people and this is the best we can do I
don't think so I will tell you I know
some Democrats that would blow all of
those Democrats away but they didn't run
maybe they just didn't want to run
against me I've heard that maybe it's
true and maybe it's not makes me feel
good but they didn't want they gonna
wait they gotta wait for another four
years but you have some Democrats that
are very impressive this is not a group
that I think was very impressive at all
mr. president
Joe Biden has
record he served as vice president for
eight years that record would include
the Iranian deal that record would
include how they reacted and responded
with the h1n1 virus he'd get to that in
more detail in a minute that record
would include 13 million more Americans
after eight years on food stamps eight
million more in poverty the lowest labor
participation rate since the 70s the
worst recovery since the 40s the lowest
homeownership rate in 51 years and that
would also include the accumulation of
more debt than all 43 presidents before
Obama Biden combined your record how do
you compare well I think what we've done
is unprecedented the largest tax cuts in
history trade deals all over the place I
mean they're they're gonna start kicking
in fairly soon unfortunately by the time
we get to the election they'll just be
partially kicked in but to deal with
China 250 billion dollars a year the
deal with Japan and it's a partial deal
I'll go back and we're gonna make it
much bigger even but it's 40 billion a
year there's a deal with South Korea the
the us/mexico a deal the US Canada deal
the USMC a combined one of the biggest
trade deals ever made to deal with China
is actually you know right in that same
category it's an incredible thing what
what we've done we've rebuilt the
military we've taken care of our vets we
got choices nobody thought we're gonna
get choice they've been trying to get
choice for over 40 years
that's veterans choice with a veteran if
they can't see a doctor quickly they go
out to a private doctor we pay the bill
and it's a great thing for our country
it's a great thing for our veterans we
got accountability so that if our
veterans are treated badly if they're
treated horribly we have say we had
sadists and the VA we had all sorts of
problems thieves you couldn't do a thing
you couldn't fire anybody
I got accountability pass which was not
easy because of unions and because of
civil service and you know all of the
reasons that everybody would understand
very easily and we got that pass they've
been trying to get that for many many
decades you know what we've done is very
unprecedented nobody's done more in
three years the first three years than
we have now environmentally we're we
have the cleanest air we have the
cleanest water our air is as clean or
cleaner than it's ever been and yet
we're not spending trillions of dollars
giving it to foreign countries under the
Paris Accord where you see what's
happening with France and you see the
problems they have because of it and you
know they're just trying to take our
wealth that whole group so a lot of
things are happening our economy is
doing fantastically we got hit with the
coronavirus and that was out of surprise
I started hearing about it they looked
very quietly a couple of months ago from
China and I said well that doesn't
happen over here they get a little bit
more a little bit more a little bit
bigger and against the advice of a lot
of great professionals frankly and they
work they worked for the administration
and outside I closed the borders to
China and that's why we have a very
small number of people that we have to
really worry about and you know a lot of
things that have happened that have been
very fortunate but I close the borders
against the advice of a lot of people
and and it turned out to be a very wise
decision otherwise we would have had you
know a lot of people coming in during
that course of course of a number of
weeks so I give you you know we're doing
a great job we have a great group but
Mike Pence is doing a fantastic job I
put him in charge of of the group then
we have the greatest doctors in the
world we're also helping other countries
we help a lot of other countries we
would even help Iran if they wanted you
know their it very hard but we're
helping a lot of other countries mr.
president I have the timeline and you
know unfortunately these pandemics pop
up unfortunately people die from the flu
every year one of the great things I
love about this country is the
innovation that our great scientists and
medical professionals they rise to the
occasion all the time and I'll get to
h1n1 and but Biden Obama how they
reacted the w-h-o identified on December
30th of last year that there was a virus
with pneumonia like symptoms it was
January
and when they labeled it the coronavirus
I want to go to your decision of January
31st and that was a travel ban that Joe
Biden said was xenophobic on your part
and might CNN said my stigmatized people
from countries but you took an added
step that hadn't been done in decades
and that was quarantine Americans coming
back from the region this is about three
weeks after we just first identified the
virus you're saying that people
recommended you'd not do this and why
and why did you go with that so quickly
him and what was the what was your
ration all the time well I would say
everybody said it's too early it's too
soon and good people you know brilliant
people in many ways doctors and lawyers
and frankly a lot of people that work on
this stuff almost exclusively and they
said don't do it and my theory was that
you know we take a lot of people in and
China was being hit hard at that time by
that time we started reading a little
bit more about it it wasn't something
that were was going to affect us you
know you don't think of it in terms when
you first heard it in China you don't
think our country is going to be
affected and I thought it was a wise
thing to do and again we stopped
tremendous numbers of people coming in
from China and then we worked on a whole
quarantine system which worked out very
well you know one of the things we did
the numbers are small when you're
talking around a hundred people but we
brought in approximately 40 people from
a ship they're Americans but they were
on a ship you know all about that we
brought them in and I knew that when I
bring them in immediately our numbers
get higher now again compared to some
countries we're talking about very small
numbers in this in our country very very
small because of what we did with the
borders but I brought in actually
approximately 40 a little bit more than
that from outside because they're
Americans we had to take care of them
they were left in sort of a balance they
were in the middle of nowhere and I felt
we had to do it and in one way I hated
to do it statistically I hated to do it
from the standpoint of having people
coming in that's gonna you know is it
gonna look bad I was
worried about the the other people
catching it very much because their
people are so good and we had quarantine
setup but we brought in a lot of people
now a lot of those people now getting
better very much so and we'll be
releasing them and I think we should
probably when we release them when
people are better we release them and we
reduce our numbers so we've been doing
really well it does have a big impact on
older people and people that aren't well
and it has very little impact on young
people especially very young people
which is interesting much much less so
than a lot of other infections or
viruses so we've learned a lot we're
learning a lot right now but older
people like the nursing home in
Washington the state of Washington has
been very very heavily affected the
people are much older and many of them
are not very well you know and when it's
funny you say that because the h1n1
virus that was a pandemic in 2009 and 10
interestingly in obama-biden years we
lost around 17,000 Americans the CDC
estimates are we lost 200 to 500
thousand lives worldwide in that case
children were more at risk with the h1n1
pandemic dr. Anthony Falchi who I've
watched for years he is a great
scientist
he's been very cautious and you know has
said that this could become another
pandemic like we experienced two no.9
and 2010 he said it might be as long as
a year before we ultimately get a
vaccine or there are 20 specific
vaccines presently in development you
have said that you are evaluating on a
daily basis for those Americans that
might be fearful tonight that those that
might be talking about well potential
down the road will close down schools
and maybe there'll be more telecommuting
kind of working situations what do you
say to them based on as this develops
what do we prepared as a country to do
to keep our citizens safe
well I just say that it's you know a
very very small number in this country
and we're going to try and keep it that
way as much as possible I will say
though the h1n1
that was swine flu commonly referred to
as swine flu and that went from around
April of o.9 to a pretend where there
were sixty million cases of swine flu
and you know over actually it's over
thirteen thousand I think you might have
said 79 hurt it was 13 but a lot of a
lot of deaths and they didn't do
anything about it interestingly with the
swine flu children were in particular
they were vulnerable sort of the
opposite in that respect but children
were very vulnerable to the swine flu
but they never did close the borders I
don't think they ever did have the
travel band and we did and again they
lost at least 13,000 it could be as high
as 17,000 people and have reacted much
differently and then you know I watched
Biden try and criticize us but I'm not
sure he knows what he's criticizing to
be honest with you but I watched him the
other day try or a watch humor every
time they put a mic in his face he has
no idea the incredible job these people
are doing here say oh they're doing a
horrible job horrible job well he says
that because that's like the order you
know he'll say it about anything if you
say how great is the deal with China oh
I don't like it I don't like it he said
he took away tariffs so I didn't take
away the tariffs they're paying 25
percent of two hundred and fifty billion
dollars they pay us a tariff of 25
percent on two hundred and fifty billion
but he was screaming he took away the
tariffs you know he didn't want the
tariffs and then all of a sudden when he
thinks they would take it away but we
didn't take em away just the opposite
it was rather incredible that we didn't
take them away but that's the way it is
we're getting along very well with China
we're dealing with China President Xi
who I speak with President Xi is working
very very hard and Shatter they have a
big problem but their numbers have
gotten much better with respect with
respect to the corona virus very much
better yeah well there are a couple
economic indicators and I know markets
tend to be skittish although really
wasn't during the h1n1 swine flu period
which is interesting to me but they seem
to be adjusting and accepting that that
all that I guess can be done is being
done we do have some economic numbers
just out u.s. economy
service sector grew in February at the
fastest pace in a year of CNBC report on
ADP their job report that the economy
adding jobs in February
despite the coronavirus scare as private
payrolls expanded their they are saying
employment excluding government jobs
rose by 183 thousand for the month do
you expect maybe a short-term slowdown
and at all in the economy as a result of
the virus and maybe of course it's a
global economy China's the impact on
China's economy in particular well I
think we're just doing very well it's a
very interesting you know four years
you've known me and I'm sort of saying
keep it within the borders a little bit
more let's make our own medicines here
and you know we've already started that
long before I heard about this before we
knew about the corona virus but I've
started it but I've been a big person
for let's keep it a little bit inside
I'm not a I'm not a globalist I like our
country to do well and I'm certainly
interested in this love where we're
working with them to help them in a lot
of different ways including including
the virus that we're talking about right
now but you know I've been saying stay
here well now people are actually
staying here and that's okay let let
some time go by and they're staying here
but if they want they can travel and
they're going to save countries you I
met with the top airline executives at
top people and virtually every major
airline today in this country and
they're very aware of it and and their
ending flights to certain areas certain
areas of Italy which has been hit hard
not the whole country but certain areas
and other places and China very big in
terms of China so a lot of things are
happening and frankly if people want to
spend their money in the United States
instead of traveling abroad I'm very
fine with that I think that's great
numbers are coming out very well the
consumer in the United States is
unbelievably strong stronger than ever
before I believe and that's why we're
doing so well in other countries they're
not doing well
the European Union is not doing well the
as you know parts of Asia China is not
doing well beyond beyond the virus is
not doing well and and we're doing great
so you know I think we're going to be in
great shape and this will go and this
will pass and working on vaccines right
now we're working on therapeutic
measures and we're working at a lot of
things I was I was with some of the
greatest doctors in the world over the
last two days and they're saying what
they can do today is it's incredible
what they're doing and what they've been
able to do and and they're able to do it
much faster so we're getting some very
good very good ideas that I think you're
gonna have things happening pretty
quickly you extended your travel ban you
met with the pharmaceutical companies in
the country I understand you're meeting
with you're going down to Atlanta to
meet with the CDC leadership I know you
have vice president pence at the helm of
running this task force and people like
dr. Anthony found cheese is warning it
could be a pandemic it could get worse
and at times we might have to take more
more severe safety measures we have a
report today the global death rate at
three point four percent and a report
that the Olympics could be delayed your
reaction to that well I think the three
point four percent is really false
number now this is just my hunch and but
based on a lot of conversations with a
lot of people that do this because a lot
of people will have this and it's very
mild they'll get better very rapidly
they don't even see a doctor they don't
even call it doctor you never hear about
those people so you can't put them down
in the in the category of the overall
population in terms of this Korona flu
and or virus so you just can't do that
so if you know we have thousands or
hundreds of thousands of people that get
better there just by you know sitting
around and even going to work some of
them go to work but they get better and
then when you do have a death like
you've had in the state of Washington
like you had one in California I believe
you had one in New York
you know all of a sudden it seems like
three or four percent which is a very
high number as opposed to as opposed to
a fraction of one percent but again they
don't they don't know about the easy
cases because the easy cases don't go to
the hospital they don't report to
doctors or the hospital in many cases so
I think that that number is very high I
think the number personally I would say
the number is way under 1% now with the
regular flu you know we average from
27,000 to 77 thousand deaths a year who
would think that I'd never do that until
six or eight weeks ago I asked a
question I said how many people died of
the flu you know you keep hearing about
flu shots Lucia take your flu shot but I
said how many people died of the flu and
they said sir we lose between 27,000 and
you know somewhere in the 70s
I think we went as high as a hundred
thousand people died in 1990 if you can
believe that but a lot of people
regardless I think it averages about
36,000 people a year so I said wow and
that's now that's on a percentage that's
under 1% very substantially so it'd be
interesting to see what that difference
is difference is but again a lot of
people don't report because they they
get the corona virus and they get better
relatively quickly got that severe what
do you say about the politics that if
you kill a terrorist named soleimani
number one state-sponsored terrorism
Iran the guy leading those terrorist
efforts is Soleimani a miracle with our
intelligence the 99% of good
intelligence officials that tracked him
down to a Baghdad Airport knowing he was
in a commercial air flight which is
amazing they could have shot that on the
plane but they we care about human life
and they wait until he was on the ground
you don't get a lot of support even on
something like that if something I would
think we would all agree on a virus is
another example where it is it is
non-discriminating they don't it'll
attack Republicans Democrats
conservatives and liberals and even as
quickly as you acted I you were attacked
for it
xenophobe you're stigmatizing [ __ ]
when I assume that your interest for the
best interest the American people what
does it say about the state of our
politics we can't even agree to work
together on solving a virus that will
attack all of us
well shun the Democrats weaponized the
virus against the Trump administration
they weaponized anything we do and yet
if they did it they'd be you know
hailing it but they do weaponize this
you know when they know what a great job
we're doing would they know we have the
best in the world we have and we're
really shown it even when you look at
the small numbers that we're talking
about within this country they're very
very small I mean we have a you know
very large country to put it mildly and
then a great country by the way and it's
getting greater all the time but they
weaponize the virus against us and you
know they'll just say even though they
have no facts so just say oh we don't
like the job they're doing you know it's
just off the cuff is like a natural
reflex and it's not good especially it's
not good with something like this you
know they can say it about certain
things but this one everybody has to
pull together and not all Democrats have
done that I must say lately I noticed
that it's gotten really a lot less I
would say 50% less but you know the same
the bad ones the Schumer's and others
they will always say no matter how good
you do if you found a cure and
everything disappeared within 24 hours
you'd say you did a terrible job
terrible terrible and that's unfortunate
for the country but you know we live
with it and Here I am in the White House
I'm president and they're not it's sort
of an amazing factor isn't it
244 days the American people are the
ultimate jury as I say let me go back to
that election for a second it was very
early on when Mike Bloomberg got in a
race you said you're wasting your money
but almost 600 million dollars estimates
anywhere between 5 and 12 million per
delegate he's now out of the race what
did you see a lot of people thought he
might do better why did his campaign not
catch on well once he debated I said
he's going to be in trouble because it's
not his thing and he's a smart guy he's
a you know smart guy in a certain way at
a different kind of way but not in a
political way he's got a very bad
political instinct he's surrounded by
people that I know in some cases
no pretty well they're losers he's
really surrounded by losers but they
become winners because they ripped him
off for a lot of money they really took
him to the cleaners but some of these
guys are really third-rate people and
they wanted him to keep going and you
know the longer he goes the more money
they make that's why they did it because
they knew that that it's not for him and
I will tell you I thought the strategy
was incredible when the DNC wouldn't let
him in the debates he should have kept
it that way if he would have kept it
that way he would have done I don't
think he could have won but he would
have done much better he did really
badly but he would have done much better
and then today as you notice he said all
I'm going to support I'm going to
support Joe Biden and that's okay I mean
that's fine but I don't know how you can
do it I mean how can you how does
campaign finance laws how do they let
you do that but he wants to he couldn't
get out fast enough I guarantee he was
on that debate when a very mean she is a
very mean person
you could ask Bernie Sanders because
what she's done to him is terrible but
when Elizabeth Warren went after him he
was saying get me off this stage get me
off here fast
he he got beat up very badly by
Elizabeth Warren that was not a pretty
sight to watch and that was the end of
him I mean it's incredible but it was so
bad that was the end of him it ended
right there and he was unable to recover
from the debate performance especially
the first one are you convinced now it's
biden's to lose I think so I just don't
know you know how he gets there I don't
know how he gets across the line maybe
he will maybe it's so knows he was
always very gaffe prone he was always he
was always in trouble in that way but
never like this you know this is going
what's going on now is crazy but I think
they'll do anything to assume power and
if they think he can do better than
Bernie and I guess they have less
control over Bernie you know Bernie is
more for himself but I was surprised
when Bernie got beaten up last time that
he went out and endorsed Hillary and
went around and did like a good puppy
like he's supposed to do I was a little
surprised at that and even this time he
was
how wonderful you know Joe Biden is a
wonderful guy wonderful man and um you
know I'm a little bit surprised by it's
almost like he's I don't know if he's
admitting defeat he might be but I
watched him yesterday saying or just a
little while ago saying very good things
about sleepy Joe Biden and I was a
little bit surprised let me ask you in
nineteen twenty sixteen you had about 8%
of the african-american vote but we've
carried a lot of your rallies as you
point out in every appearance that they
you have record low unemployment now for
african-americans Hispanic Americans
Asian Americans women in the workplace
youth unemployment african-american
youth unemployment I can cite you polls
with african-american support for Donald
Trump
anywhere from sixteen to thirty four
point five percent one case 33% another
case thirty two percent do you think
that these are why do you think these
are approval ratings demographically
have shifted one and two will that
translate in your view and votes in two
hundred forty four days well it should
translate but I think one of the reasons
is criminal justice reform I did it
nobody else could have done it we got
some great Republican senators that
maybe weren't so inclined and I
explained it to him and they were really
great really great I saw Alice Johnson
today she was in jail for twenty two
years and she had done it twenty to go
and there was a crime that you know she
admitted she did a mistake but she was
in there for it was like a life sentence
for something that somebody else would
have been given six months to a year for
or a very small number she's a great
woman and she I said you have other
people just like you Alice just like
your they she said oh yes there are
other people and I actually that three
out they all came to the office today
was great to see them three great people
but I think that criminal justice reform
we got that I got that the Democrats did
not get it I got it they they will
probably at some point try and take
credit but they couldn't do it and again
this was a Biden Obama law that was you
know this was and and obviously it was
it was really a Hillary if this
was a Bill Clinton and a Hillary and it
was I guess Biden was a senator then and
pushing it hard obama was somebody said
he was talking about it but he had to be
pretty young if that was the case but
this was a horrible thing and so
criminal justice reforms one Opportunity
Zones that's the great Tim Scott he's a
great guy he's a senator and a great
senator from South Carolina then he came
to my office talked about Opportunity
Zones and massive amounts of money is
being poured into areas that haven't
seen money in decades and jobs and
people are really doing well and the
african-american population is doing
phenomenally well the Hispanic
population is doing incredibly well
Opportunity Zones is is another thing
and you know the unemployment rate we
have the lowest black unemployment rate
if you look the black community right
now has the lowest unemployment rate in
the history of our country Hispanic
American unemployment rate the lowest in
the history of our country Asian the
lowest in the history of our country
women the lowest in 71 years and you
know so many things are happening and it
is true I mean we're having rallies now
with black young leaders that are
unbelievable people and they'll come to
the White House they'll have six seven
hundred people they'll have rallies
outside in different cities for Trump
because it's the first time they've
really been helped nobody's the
Democrats a cater to them months before
an election and then they leave and they
don't do a damn thing for them and we've
worked hard so between I think criminal
justice reform and the opportunity zones
it's incredible what what Tim Scott did
with Opportunity Zones is really
incredible and how well it's worked so
there but the end result is the lowest
unemployment rate and I think people see
that I think they see it strongly
showing there's also been a lot of
support for historically black colleges
in the country as well I mean let me ask
you this might the the historically
black colleges I got to know a lot of
the deans and the people and they come
you know now I'm here more than three
years they come
every year trying to get money then
after two three years I said why do you
guys have to come back every year they
said well nobody's ever given we've
always have to come back and one of them
said we feel like beggars coming into
the White House begging for money I said
we shouldn't have to do that you
shouldn't have to do that and I got them
long-term financing for the historically
black colleges and universities and
they're great people I got to know them
very well they serve such an incredible
you know such an incredible group of
people and such an incredible and
important function and it's a very large
you know you're talking about millions
of people are educated and taken care of
and it's really something good but they
don't have to do that they don't have to
come back in fact I said to them I'll
miss you people not coming up to see me
I'll miss you guys
I'll miss you gals not coming up to see
me every year but they I don't think
they could be any more thankful they
don't have to bother now they don't have
to do that when you instituted your
travel ban on January 31st we identified
Corona on January 7th and the quarantine
it was in the middle of your impeachment
James Comey you know at all of your
rallies you say this should never happen
to any future president you fired James
Comey we know all about the dirty
Russian dossier that was never
verifiable the top of a FISA warrant
says verified we now know it's been
debunked Hillary paid for it and that it
became the basis the bulk of information
for FISA applications to take away
Carter pages civil liberties and
constitutional rights but more
importantly it was used and the Attorney
General has confirmed this to spy on you
as a candidate your transition team and
his words deep into your presidency I
know that we've had the Inspector
General weigh in now we have the dorm
bar investigation going forward what
what without crossing at the territory
that I assume is different how does this
how do we prevent something like this
from ever happening again I I'm a big
believer we need FISA we need to be able
to
and trust Americans with these powerful
tools because we've got a lot of enemies
in this world but it raises questions if
it's going to be turned on the American
people or on a presidential candidate or
president well they weaponized FISA and
they used it horribly and Comey is a
very bad guy and you have other very bad
people at the top the FBI the people in
the FBI are incredible I'll bet if they
did a study if you took a vote I'd have
a vast vast vast majority they're
incredible people but the top the top
people the people that headed it between
Comey and McCabe and and struck and his
lover lisa page and all group it was a
bad group that's my opinion and it's a
very strong opinion we'll see how bad it
was nobody was willing to vet Barack
Obama at the time we did that job I'm
proud of the ensemble cast we built was
we we tore apart the Espionage Act and
classified top-secret information on
Hillary server and deleted subpoenaed
emails and the dirty dossier and
premeditated fraud on a FISA Court we've
been vindicated with the Inspector
General report and I I guess I never
thought that this could happen in
America but the media got it wrong
Russia Russia Ukraine Ukraine and that's
been a lot to go through well it has but
they knew it was wrong and they knew
they were wrong and the whole thing
that's why call it the fake news for
that and many other reasons but it is
fake news so much of it is fake and
knowingly fake and they knew that was
wrong they knew the first day it should
have never happened but I went through
it I did it and you think of it after
millions they spend millions and
millions of dollars and at the end
unlimited resources no collusion
somebody said you're the cleanest person
in the country but it was a disgrace
that a lot of people were hurt and hurt
badly let's see what happens let's see
what happens going forward all right mr.
president you've been very generous with
your time
I know you're doing a town hall on Fox
here tomorrow with Brett and Martha with
I get to take questions from the
American people we'll look forward to
watching that you're always generous
with your time we like to get the stated
not only the campaign the country
obviously a lot going on thank you for
your time thank you very much John thank
you thank you